okay
in North America driving home for
Christmas comes with a danger warning
an Arctic Storm blowing through the
United States and parts of Canada is
already closing roads and canceling
flights ahead of the festive Rush
forecasters are predicting brutally cold
temperatures accompanied by powerful
winds and snow
as the white out spreads the White House
has spoken
please take this storm extremely
seriously
and I don't know whether your boss was
elected but if you all have travel plans
to leave now
not not a joke I'm sending my staff
my staff if they had plans to leave on
tomorrow it's a late tonight or tomorrow
tell them to leave now this was a tweet
from a State Trooper in Kansas out on
the road struggling in the snow
you have to travel really really slow to
be able to stay within the roadways
are
nearly 200 million people are in areas
with some kind of weather warning
amidst predictions of the coldest
festive season in decades Christmas
trade has turned from presence to
preparations when we're seeing temps of
15 in wind chills of like -1 and -5 that
really shows you how rare this is the
ice apocalypse is coming upon us
tomorrow
and I want to do some of my neighbors
walkways and my own
to head home or to hunker down it's a
Christmas question facing Millions here
although travel won't be the only
concern as the conditions bite
James Matthews Sky News in Washington